hello and welcome to this video playing
some sketchy cage lost I have no idea
okay and let's play something funky I'm
heat pre-move t5 well you can probably
do that in the French what a funny line
okay Bishop Bishop bird to be four so I
cannot grab reform seems that he wants
to take on c3 and yeah keep them keep
the pawn for the moment even though I
have my doubts that he is going to keep
it I mean well he can take but I can so
he's shooting he's shooting for Bishop
e3 maybe yeah okay that's not going to
work so easily push up a three f Knight
f6 I can actually take with the Queen
then that's a funny motif Knight f6
Queen f6 s Bishop e3 that's Queen a1
checkmate it's quite cute actually okay
i guess i have to take and see what what
happens here um yeah just default
probably
and King position is not completely
ideal but with that the bishop but ok
I've got got center and my development
is pretty ok
interesting maybe a good a for him
okay I'm going to check see that I'm
that I'm making sure that I'm not gain
chick made it it's not the most elegant
way ever to play but maybe maybe
interesting I was thinking qg five
actually but maybe i can also play
Bishop d3 for the moment if he cancels i
actually have the greek gift i think
queen is coming from b-52h five and
diamond probably our thinking I was
thinking d5 this may be a move here but
you will take take me three I guess okay
after maybe switch back to plan B 25 oh
d 5 mm now d5 look doesn't look very
reliable so let's do this
sketch shake I mean this is this is
something Italian for chess at each loss
does he have a name their chest jokes
are not funny probably not okay okay
here probably chat we'll check him yeah
so he really wants to kill me down on
the side of the board but night age 44
night g6 once the Teague take be three
and then play Queen Adrienne tent-mate
it's a pretty drastic but um so one
night each for takes takes takes be 396
chick takes it clean h8 king of seven I
don't really have a good move um in this
position
okay let's play a defensive move here
it's not that everything is golden on
his side of the board here with f6 and
so on my main concern is that i'm pretty
dumb on time I mean the position might
also be bad but time issue is some can
get very tricky
like to play d5 something d5 and rookie
10 that's a that's an interesting move
very likely a good one asking my queen
about about its position okay it's
probably not an ideal square which
thinking along now no good idea now
while the light squares I could have
gone to g4 bit UNH five then is an idea
very tough very tough for both sides
here yeah that is something that I was
thinking about I wasn't sure if that
does help Bishop a 393 rook takes Queen
cheeks and he's probably crashing
through and a 2 hangs this is the the
biggest issue ok I can take on a to
write takes takes Knight a2 and I can
also from they just take now him yeah
poor just taking on b3 probably would
work on yeah plus that time morning and
whatever then what what's what's what
put what TX Texas is made
I have no moves here
absolutely no move to even continue and
yeah I don't know wow what a bad game
check check no we can win with whatever
95 or whatever Wow yeah could have
defended better I mean probably yes but
that was pretty awful no probably
shouldn't play offbeat lines wherever
I've done this successfully in the past
but whenever you you lose a crappy game
like that you always tell her why not
why didn't I play something something
something simple yeah that that that I
know okay check some of the game is
continuing which is good and it's not
Odin immediate made it seems check
it's the lost wait for things one time I
can't was bad bad bad it's not such a
bad line for white actually it's it's
it's it's clearly a playable
continuation so chic sticks do you for I
mean this cannot be so bad my
development is pretty okay and now he
just pledges and this is a tech down
yeah I don't think this is so bad but f
six min f six Chan it looks weird but
maybe black Sutekh is just just a bit
too strong that's really possible it's
tough to defend it's tough to defend and
I don't have time for them I would love
to play an active move like that but you
just takes and threatens this in q3
you're just devastating so yeah after
that I'm losing grew k5 is also the best
move this is what the engine is giving
check it doesn't look very inviting but
maybe now can probably cannot take as
root k 1 is stripping the Queen so it
might be still okay I mean the engine is
only giving black a slight advantage 0.4
and this is rook air-five is very strong
and I before it's also strong move yeah
I probably should have taken another
dead dis lose but I didn't see it was
something that would work I mean this is
that according to the comp not that bad
actually which surprises me but well
yeah okay he's running out of attacking
pieces a little bit I was thinking he
can just stay here but the computer
points out this resource attacking the
pawn that's pretty strong actually I
mean not like white is better but that
that's a completely playable position
now I didn't see that F Queenie
form again does this mean okay I wasn't
pretty much aware that I'm losing here
but I didn't see how to avoid it yeah
and here many Japanese away some check
and check and many way when you weigh as
a win no check that suppose so that was
a pretty drastic loss yeah sometimes
tricky of you don't know the ins and
outs them it's a bit it's a bit bit bit
awful if you have like spend two minutes
after after 10 10 12 moves or something
that can get back to you I'd you played
that nicely as family that allowing this
and playing okay five is pretty strong
that's pretty strong okay well thanks
for watching